let's talk about russia a little bit in
the sanctions and kind of the fun i'll
call it that russians can avoid
sanctions by the united states european
union and other uh nato countries in
swift by using bitcoin so david zell had
a great um great post that he did with
the bitcoin policy institute um which
basically he went through all the
reasons uh he went through all the
reasons that russia actually can't use
this and the first one he basically said
was that bitcoin is actually too small
to use right so to replace a dollar
their pre-word exports total 400 billion
dollars around 50 of the current market
cap
and to be able to use this it's hard for
russia to predict or manage its
commodity revenues if they go ahead and
they pr price their commodities and
their reserves in bitcoin rather
russia's substantial gold and yen
reserves make those assets a more viable
backup to support ongoing limited trade
activity um and then it went on to state
that major exchanges can restrict
compliance because they can
exchanges can actually comply with the
united states um some centralized
exchanges that can actually shut down
users account and go ahead and um go
ahead and impose those sanctions by not
letting them use bitcoin almost and they
are highly responsive to blacklist
designated addresses and non-compliant
exchanges and then sanctioned violators
will have a hard time hiding their
transactions right so bitcoin is a
public ledger that people can see all
the transactions and who's sending what
to what wallet and where is it going and
how is it being distributed um and
bitcoin is a perfect example that the
criminals actually do not like using
bitcoin solely because they how easily
it can be tracked down to you so the
people that did the bitfinex exchange
hack in 2016 it took a while but it was
pretty easy to find out almost who did
this right um maybe not easy for an
individual like myself but for the fbi
and other government officials um and
agencies it's pretty easy to track a
public ledger where you can see
everything and then see hey it went
through 18 different wallets and then
ended up in this person's bank account
for them to actually go ahead and spend
it and then go be disputed digital
settlement system bitcoin allows anyone
to transfer value peer-to-peer without
centralized intermediates um amidst the
crisis ukraine citizens ngos and the
ukraine government itself have turned to
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies to raise
more than 22 million aid at the time of
this post
every russian are turning to bitcoin and
dollar peg stable coins to escape the
collapsing ruble so this is actually
very very good for the citizens of
russia but not so good for the
government of russia um
to use this and then sanctions that
limit russians citizens access to
cryptocurrencies would violate a core
principle of u.s policies articulated by
deputy national security adviser dileep
singh to only impose sanctions that are
targeted to avoid the appearance of
punishing the russian
uh
civilian
civilian sorry population having a hard
day today i also flew back from tanzania
last night so don't worry about it um
but yeah this is look it's really
unfortunate for the citizens of russia
because they get hurt a lot by these
sanctions by the united states and other
nations around the world um and bitcoin
kind of is that safe haven but i don't
think it's a viable option for russia
and the russian government to use
bitcoin as hey this is now our reserve
currency instead of using the united
states dollar other foreign currencies
yeah i i think it goes back to what we
were saying earlier which is uh you just
want control over something where other
people can't make decisions right so
whether it's a nation state or an
individual i think that
having sovereignty over your own money
is important right i think we we've
established that point but on a broader
scale when it comes to russia's i think
uh the quote you were reading earlier
was 50
of their financial assets are not
controlled by them right or in
currencies that are established within
other people that want to do harm to
them or want control over them so when
you have a majority of your money uh
within uh things outside of of your
currency and people have access to
control them to impose sanctions to
freeze them to freeze your assets and
and really take custody of them then
you're in a you're in a position where
you can't defend yourself when it comes
to things financially so whether it's
you know five percent 10 100 it doesn't
really matter but i think the general
idea still stands bitcoin is not good
for criminals because it can be traced
it can be tracked you can do all these
different things some aspect of it is uh
yes politicians and government officials
and police officers and the fbi and all
these organizations would rather that
you use bitcoin because it's more
traceable right so there's there's a
degree of that that's certainly true
but when it comes to nation states i
think it's just about the dependence on
another currency right so if you have
all of your assets in a foreign currency
your currency starts to collapse your
other assets get freezed and you start
to do things to manipulate it so your
your currency stops falling then you're
in a position where you can't really
defend yourself financially so i think
bitcoin is obviously a solution for that
it depends on kind of what you're trying
to do right if you're trying to fund a
war if you're trying to fund all these
different things to hurt other countries
and they can easily see where their
money's coming from and all these
different things and that's a different
story but in my mind uh bitcoin is
obviously extremely important for the
individual and then it comes to a nation
state it reduces their risk or their
dependence on other currencies that they
do not have control over right so if
russia had a larger percentage of their
uh central bank assets within bitcoin or
something else and they wanted to do
something and not have such
the general point is right those
sanctions wouldn't have had as great of
an impact if they had bitcoin or other
assets on their balance sheet but what
we're seeing is when you own a bunch of
us dollars or assets that are held with
outside of your central bank assets held
other places in the world and they can
freeze those they can impose sanctions
they can do these different things kick
you off swift and all this other stuff
like it becomes very dangerous very
quickly not only for yourself as a
nation but for all your citizens living
there yeah i mean having a couple
hundred or a few hundred billions of
dollars um or other currencies frozen
outside of your central bank is a very
very big deal
i wonder if the play is almost hey let's
hurt not hurt the people enough but
let's cause enough ruckus in their
economy and their financial system that
the people actually stand up and say hey
you're hurting the value of my dollar my
rupal um and now literally everything
i've worked for is just worth less
because you guys have decided to go to
war and hopefully i think they're trying
to basically start that fire within um
within the country on the ground with
the actual um citizens of russia
basically saying hey let's not go to war
this is causing more harm than good for
our nation um but i doubt that's gonna
happen in my world um from what i
understand it is putin's russia and
they're gonna do whatever the government
what he kind of wants to do hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time